what the is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed hello everybody and
welcome back
seriously i wish you guys were here to
see
what that intro was before just with no
music
um yeah y'all are y'all are sleeping on
our
youtube channel all right unwaxed has a
youtube channel
you can watch the podcast live i feel
like i'm talking
directly to you guys at home watching
this so
it's kind of fun yeah how you feeling
today i'm feeling good
i'm feeling you know what actually i'm
not feeling good that's a lie
why sometimes when i feel really tired
and like
look and just run down for no reason you
know you wake up some days and you're
just like no
totally just one of them days
this no today's been off i i have to say
even this morning i feel so bad
i just told cysteine i spaced on my best
friend's birthday i knew
it was this week i knew it was this week
but i swear i thought today was a
certain day
and i thought it was tomorrow and so i
was talking to her all morning
asking her advice on like photos and
this and this and i completely
and also when i saw her post that it was
and it
i and by i'm not one to forget
yeah birthdays like i'm but i am i'll
play devil's advocate
i am definitely one to forget i don't
know if it's just me or anyone else out
there but i'm terrible
at remembering dates so my little trick
to know if it's a friend's birthday i'll
know it's in november
or or july but i shouldn't know the
exact day
either i go on snapchat because it'll
put a little birthday cake next to that
person's name
or i'll go to my instagram find
last year's birthday post look at the
exact date and do it that way oh
no but i'm so like i am a planner i
write down everyone's birthdays in my
calendar but since
we've been here i feel like everything
is so backwards like i'm trying to
understand the area and i just like my
sleep patterns are off and
i don't know if it's the humidity is
just getting to my head and now i'm just
spacing but
whatever but i was going to say that
speaking of this
like our emotions being totally weird
last night i was
lucid dreaming i don't know if you've
ever no way yeah and i haven't
dreamed in so long what exactly is lucid
dreaming
so lucid dreaming from what i know is
you can control your dreams correct me
if i'm wrong but i i feel like there is
a way to train yourself
to i do know how to train yourself
someone told me
that basically right before it's a
certain level of rem sleep that you have
to be in
so right when you first fall asleep the
first 15 minutes that you fall asleep
you have to have someone that you trust
so it couldn't be you or scarlet for me
because you guys would probably play a
joke on me or film me or something it
has to be someone you trust and they
have to go up to you
and whisper very carefully and quietly
sofia you're dreaming you're asleep
yeah yeah asmr and
basically that tells your brain
that you are awake i don't really know
the rest of it i i know that there are
ways to kind of do it where
you are supposed to set an alarm for
like three a.m and you wake yourself up
and you write down what you remember
yeah the writing down and it's also
trying to recall one certain item in
your dream like a red ball bouncing that
means
you're in a dream you're lucid dreaming
or a watch that has like eight hands
like people start doing that
but sometimes i think that you can lucid
dreams on purpose like or not on purpose
on accident without really knowing
you're about to do it like i
last night woke up at like 2 a.m and i
went back to sleep and don't you feel
like when you wake up
and then go back to sleep your your
dreams are so much more vivid
because you're not technically fully but
that's what it is you're mine i love
waste dreams
oh right it's so great because your
mind's still awake and your body i mean
is totally asleep but my dream was i
was just placed into willy wonka's
chocolate factory kind of
i agree because the like those munchkins
and like the things that people were
getting sucked into that kind of freaks
me out
but it was really fun to like kind of
control and then i actually pictured
like other rooms like a cotton candy
room
like jump up and down and i like created
myself to have wings
at one point if you were in that movie
and you had to have
one of the fate of those kids which one
would you
just hate to have the most okay i was
violet the one that turned
blue i think it would be of them it
would be the violet turning into a
blueberry or
getting sucked into that chocolate small
tube that camera do you remember when
you got sucked into i do
that would give me claustrophobia i have
a freaking
squirrel girl remember
are you kidding me that just wait oh my
god
that movie and what is another film
that's a ch a children's film
that idrimanji jumanji yo yo
jumanji you guys jumanji not the one
with
what's the nick jonas and the wrong no
no no that's
like the real jumanji the original was
robin williams
yeah he was okay it's a great film now
but as a kid nightmares nightmares
terrified it was so scary
yeah even else is like that for me what
coraline
coraline who if anyone actually likes
coraline out there yeah you
seek therapy that's worth imagine going
through a small door
and then you have buttons on your eyes
or your whole family's buns on it and
they're trying to sew it on to you
how about james and the giant peach
oh my god i i can do you one better
than nightmare before christmas oh i
kind of like them
um we watched it on the plane it was
like on one of the stations and
always on at the yeah i know and at the
end of it people were like
the the like i don't know it what's that
bug man he's the sa he looks like the
sack he's like the evil guy yeah
i don't think he's the same man or
something he's literally just a sexy
bugs coming out of his mouth
his eyes it is horrifying it's
definitely not a christmas you know what
show we do love to watch right now
jersey shore i feel like every week
that we come on this podcast we're
obsessed with a new thing yeah
this week it's jersey shore and let me
tell you guys this is the fourth time
fourth fourth time watching it from
start to finish start
not knowing and it's just season three
burst
to end yeah and it gets funnier every
time it is
so good i don't understand how it you
know
it just tell reality shows then are so
different from the healthy artists all
of
one episode of jersey shore would never
be allowed on tv today
it just would never happen like the
things that were like this just
calling girls grenades like that you
can't do that she smells like kicked her
out of my bed i was
just so so it's chef's kiss beautiful
it's so good
gym tan laundry oh my god the cats are
here
we could go on oh we know our days
but our guest is about to come on and
when i tell you and i know we say this
just between you and me i know we say
this about a lot of our guests
but this one is an og
we have been wanting her since
before our podcast was even i mean not
that we were lying before but this was
like
the one we really you know sometimes you
just throw a name out there
it's a reach it's a dream guest a dream
guest she's too busy
she's booked and busy she's too fabulous
to come on unwaxed
somehow we got her on on wax we tricked
her into coming on our
guys we have the fabulous
sex expert emily
sex with emily is coming on unwaxed
right now stay tuned you don't want to
miss it
she's an author and a doctor in human
sexuality but in 2005 she began the
podcast sex with emily and started
approaching the topic of sex and
relationships
in a friendly non-judgmental and
open-minded way
it is downloaded more than one million
times each month and in november 2018
sex with emily launched on siriusxm this
is emily morse
hi guys thanks for having me emily that
is the most impressive
intro i think we've ever read i was so
impressed i was like
i have that version no your credentials
i mean you
are like a walking encyclopedia
for all things sex relationships
everything i mean it's
amazing you are truly the og so we're so
lucky to have you on today
well i think it's great what you guys
are doing i love that you're doing your
podcast and you're into it you guys are
so thanks for having me i'm happy to
support i love you on my show it was so
fun people loved it i know you guys all
this together
yes oh my god of course we went on
emily's show and we had a blast and we
definitely want to continue the
conversation here and i think we should
just
jump right in because one of the main
things that all of our listeners are
constantly coming to sophia and i for
and
it's sometimes hard because they ask a
lot of confidence questions
and we're very honest and we say we
don't have
all of the confidence all of the time so
right you know we would love your advice
to sort of jump in here because
mostly what people are concerned about
is confidence in the relationship
therefore
confidence in the bedroom because it all
sort of plays hand in hand
so when you're lacking it what do you do
well you know
here's the here's the good news is that
confidence isn't something that you just
get one day and you check it off the
list and now i'm confident let me work
on other things it's like
your self-esteem you know it's all tied
in your self-esteem and your confidence
and so i think the first thing is like
just
okay if we're talking about
relationships and dating i guess people
like does he like me does he not
i always say like assume that he likes
you just he's going out with you
don't obsess all the details don't
analyze every single text
and just make that assumption like he
asked me out we're going out and then
you're not
in your head as much and these are might
even have to be something that you're
writing down before you go on the date
yeah
you know what i mean when we upset i
said this he's not gonna like me because
let me tell you
this they might not like you
it might not work out it's never for the
things you obsessed about
it's never for the thing you wore said
how drunk you were like it's just not
yeah and so you can't control it and
then we obsess
that just makes so much sense it does no
it seriously does because i think as
females i know sophie and i do this a
lot where
someone will text us we'll overthink it
we'll analyze it we'll pick it apart and
they're probably just saying
hey what's up we're like do they mean
hey what's up like you want to go out do
you want to have sex like what do you
mean hey what's up
you're so right so just assume that they
like you and just play okay so what do
you feel about
confident right yeah i mean totally yeah
and then
yeah go ahead no no go ahead sorry well
i was gonna say because the thing that
comes
after that is just know that if it
doesn't work out
it's not because it just means it wasn't
right like i always think
if it doesn't happen but i've ever heard
the saying like
god's rejection is god's protection i'm
not even that religious but it's kind of
like if someone rejects you i'm not
religious
but like i love that rejection is
protection like it happened for a reason
it happened it doesn't matter why it's
not about you
you'll probably never know and it's not
because you did anything wrong
i totally agree we had actually clint
coley come on our show
and it was our episode advice from a
[ __ ] boy so having the male point of
view he literally
said the same thing he goes you did if i
go out with a girl and it doesn't work
out
it's not because he goes she always gets
offended why don't you like me he goes
you're a great person but we're just not
great together
doesn't mean you're a bad individual so
totally
exactly we take it in like oh i did
something wrong and i gotta change and i
gotta dress different and i gotta lose
weight or i gotta gain weight like
whatever
and it's never that i love it and that's
perfect and totally translate into the
bedroom too is because
you feel like you have this pressure to
perform and you're like i got to be
sexy this this this this and in real
like real life we just need to act
confident be present no but in the
bedroom
like in the bedroom you guys look
beautiful but in the bedroom it's like
this is and this is also practice like
everyone go easy on yourself because
it's awkward it's weird it's messy
things are going to happen
but the most important thing is like
even if you get in your head like you
don't want to be tripping in the bedroom
you just want to be like
in your body what feels good to me what
how do
i want to be am i enjoying this moment
it's not about what they
what they want because most and i can
tell you this too most
guys they just want to know that they're
making you feel that you're actually
feeling good
they don't like if they knew that you
were like we're faking orgasms you know
we gotta talk about this i've done all
the things but
that's just stoking their ego and then
if you think about how we are like
sisterhood you're like well now
i faked it and now he's gonna go off
thinking he's this wonderful lover so i
might as well just kind of make him work
for my pleasure
yeah let's humble him you are not a
wonderful lover
work for it that is so funny you get
used to also doing that yourself
because it's like oh if i don't make him
think that he's doing amazing that he's
never
going to want to do it again and that's
the complete opposite
i mean like you want to be critiqued
like i want to be told if i was doing
something wrong i want to be told
like this doesn't feel good do you think
that's the best way to approach it is to
ask a guy
what can i do better yeah i mean i think
the conversation about sex
i i think it could be like let's talk
about sex that was hot so what are you
into like what felt good
do and then hopefully they'll ask you
what felt good you'd be like
i'm learning you guys i always tell
people they do this blame me
we interviewed um uh emily morris she's
gonna and it made me think i've never
done this before
and i want to actually talk about sex do
you mind practicing with me i've never
talked to a partner about it because no
one has it's not like you're gonna he's
gonna be like
well every other woman i've been with no
one's done this but this is the movement
like this is what just like
so what was that good i couldn't tell
there because you did that weird wince
thing
and then and then he'd be like what
about me and you could be like you
always want to start the compliment
sandwich
well i loved the way we were kissing but
i felt like your hand went down my pants
a little too quick but you know just
right have fun with it because then
you take away all the anxiety it becomes
a conversation and so that's how i think
the best way and then you
then it becomes fun to talk about then
you're in a dialogue about it you're not
guessing
okay that is great advice i'm going to
do this i'm going to hope all my
listeners do this
if we are too afraid we're going to say
emily told us
yeah that's perfect okay she gave a
little assignment will you practice with
me you could use that oh my god
i love it if you start out the
conversation with sex if you've never
done it with your partner
and already a light-hearted open-minded
kind of silly
it's gonna end up being that way if you
go into it with such negativity and like
self-consciousness and thinking that
they're going to also be weaseling their
way around
getting to know what they are right so
it sucks it's not like
it's this is life or death it's supposed
to be feeling we do it right
we do it for like procreation there's
like a lot i think i think though today
the way it's fun
i think the way our generation perceives
sex is
so over thought and it just
it's there's so much insecurity and and
awkwardness behind it and i feel like
the way it used to be was just free and
love and do what you want and do what
feels good and
it doesn't matter the number of sexual
partners it doesn't matter what you're
into
like everyone's i think there's some
shame i think behind
being open about having sex today yeah
bring it back i mean i'm saying like
this is what i want like if we're
thinking free love now there weren't
problems
but yeah bring that back like feel good
why do i think that is
well i have to say that i mean it's
probably
because and why it's always been this
way even in the 60s when we're like oh
fairy love there's still
a lot of shame around sex there's still
and i think it all goes back to sex
educate comprehensive sex education
like think about it you guys didn't have
great sex ed probably you had like maybe
things you can get into that yeah don't
get pregnant don't get an std or
whatever it is
and then you maybe saw sex at a really
young age right like i'm porn or you saw
porn like nine years old but it popped
up on the ipad you're like what the hell
but then there's nobody so there's no
one talking there's no conversations
about it
there's no communication you're not
gonna like talk to your parents about it
in a way that's about like oh this felt
good mom like maybe it's about
protection and
be a good whatever so there's no
information and the information you do
get is from porn
which by the way is not an accurate
portrayal of sex
at all it's not for men not bashing porn
it's got some good good assets but it's
not so you guys are left out and you're
like i
have no idea what i'm doing i'm supposed
to be sexy and what does that even mean
it's true so you're kind of like
pressure i think it's just pressure i
mean there's so many reasons why but i
think there's pressure to perform
and there's not a correction of
misinformation and i feel like a lot of
what my friends have mentioned to me
before
about like even just sex let's just say
if it's whether it's a three-day a
one-night stand to a relationship i
think people are also scared of being
seen and told about like they're bad at
sex and so they think that they have to
be great so in case that guy tells like
another person in the age of technology
everyone knows everything so it's like
oh my god
don't do well right i'm going to be seen
as bad and
it's so it's unfortunate that things
just can't be between two people and
some things
are some people are respectable like you
don't kiss and tell but that's also
another case but when you mentioned
before about
poor not being accurate cecine i wrote
this down we were thinking about media
in general not being like realistic
versus non-realistic sex because
again our health ad was just rash
i mean it i learned nothing i didn't
understand anything until i was like
halfway through high school and
i would only learn from watching film
and
tv shows and if a porn ad popped up i
was like whoa like what is happening
right now
but it was uh you're right like or it
started this dialogue that women have to
have
giant f cup boobs and be sexual all the
time in a blonde bombshell to be
attractive
right um how so for example if you see a
movie
and they're having amazing mind-blowing
sex you're like oh my god in an elevator
it takes her two years
how realistic is it it's not real it is
not real there is no way a woman's gonna
have an orgasm two minutes and now
two thirty seconds in an elevator
quickies while they're fun because
they're spontaneous
it is not the best sex of anyone's life
um
this the sex that we see in hollywood in
the movies and stuff is so not
you don't see the foreplay the warm-up
the building the kissing that when
someone's in the mood someone's not in
the mood
um the only thing i've seen do you guys
see bridgerton and
richardton which is the it's on netflix
and the reason why people are talking
about it right now
they're talking about it's shonda rhimes
new show and it's like 18th century so
the reason they're talking about it
which i i think is great is because it's
literally one of the only times i've
seen this and i was watching with my
parents in florida so it's a little
weird
even for me but it's that
he the prince right who's with the the
princess whatever she is and
he like was like no i would before they
had sex he said i want you
to touch yourself i want you to figure
out what you want
and then when they have the sex scenes
he goes down on her
and he'll just do that for like 15 20
minutes like that without me
in my mind it was longer than you don't
really see it wasn't the whole episode
and then he's like no i don't need
anything and he gets up and walk it's
like that's
because because we women like the thing
is that men and women are we're so
like what we don't get also is that our
arousal is so different we don't just
like men are frying pans and women are
still cookers do we like so it's like
men are like
turned on women the way our biology like
we need a little bit more we need
kissing we need compliments we need
whatever we need so it is just not
realistic you don't see the real thing
now of course sex can like
look like certain yes there's the
positions that you see are
accurate but as far as the whole picture
it's just not
that's so funny that you brought up
brigitte because i'm watching it right
now
and the whole internet was freaking out
about these sex scenes and i was on
episode six and i'm like where is the
sex here i don't see any of it and then
episode seven my god it just hits you
inside
yeah just keep going
but that's so funny that you said you
see it yeah it's like oh my god did i
see it
i understood why it was so hyped up i
was like okay
men take notes this is good we like this
this is good
no but it's so funny that you said like
women are such like
you know it takes a lot to turn you on
and it's hard so i always say you gotta
preheat the oven before you bake a cake
some people just try to like expect a
cake to rise when there's no
there's nothing that you didn't put the
flour the baking soda there's no heat
like what do you
yeah right exactly we got to be warmed
up we got to be
we are we can't go from zero to 60 at
all
and so that but the problem is and this
is what i remember mostly oh okay i was
gonna say mostly in my 20s but it can
still happen
because i just want to like reinforce to
you and like all your listeners that
that even like people think they know in
your 20 like they might
think they know like what what to do but
they probably don't and what makes you
good at sex
is being a good listener and being
present and experience like you don't
have as much experience even if you
slept with a hundred women
that doesn't mean you're a good lover do
you know what i'm saying so that's
totally like
that's the flip on it um but what i was
going to say is
oh god i forgot what was my question
about you said being in your 20s
oh yeah like that oh so what i found is
a sex and i said it happens everywhere
is that they
is this you make out for two seconds and
you're so into the kiss like it's
amazing and then all of a sudden they're
ripping your clothes off they're putting
they're
not even touching your breasts and
they're going right down your pants and
wanting to stick it in
and i'm telling you for the majority of
women who have vulvas vaginas
it's it's like we're not ready for it
we're not like
it feels good but if is it the best sex
of our life when you go from zero to
penetration no
what is is when there's some teasing
there's an anticipation
there's a build up they're touching you
your breasts over your shirt
they're kissing your neck like we have
so many rods than that
it's not the wham bam and i feel like i
i went for so many years i was like okay
fine do it go in not that i didn't
like it but now you realize no we need
warm-ups
i i often think do you think maybe it's
a
the older you get the wiser you get with
it because i'll have a conversation with
my friends and they'll explain that
exact scenario like
was no foreplay it just happened it
wasn't great but do you think
men are like a fine wine like the older
that they get the more experience and
then the more they want to satisfy a
lady
well you know what i found i found that
men who have been in
i've found that men who have been in
long-term relationships
they had a woman who was who a long-term
relationship with a woman who knew
this stuff they learned it from her
they're like okay well now i know
how to please a woman because someone
taught me that
or maybe they had a great mom who taught
them like but but typically like to
explain to them that women need this but
i'd like to say it's as they get older
they get better but it's usually they
have to be interested in it they have to
pay attention they have to maybe do some
research maybe they want to like my
podcast
but it's not a natural thing because i
was going to just say in your 20s but
i've been guiding those 40s and i'm like
you just still like binge on my podcast
for like listen to 30 episodes then come
back and talk to me because like they
just
you're not going to find it out by just
going about your life and because
there's women which is why i want you
guys to start this with your next date
the next guy you hook up with because
they still don't know so you can start
that with your friends and your
generation
and just say like this is this is not
you know
let them text and tweet and say like oh
she sucks she would
[ __ ] it like that's that's the price you
have to pay to train a whole new
generation of men how to be wonderful
lovers and like
i'm putting everyone up to the task
there's a risk or willingness that would
take we have to
do it and do it i think that also on the
girls side for guys
i think guys like to be touched and
kissed and talked to as well
exactly so it's on both ends it's like
they like the slow burn too maybe they
don't do it
often and they can go from zero to 100
but it's a different experience
you guys are growing and learning more
about each other it's all explorative
like this is that's an entire thing
about
sex why it's so fun is that there's
different areas that you're like oh [ __ ]
i didn't know i liked that or i didn't
know i liked hearing her say that
so it's just a shame that no one really
jumps into unless they're super
comfortable talking about that's
probably a good way to introduce it to
them if
you know you don't directly want to say
hey talk to me yeah exactly yeah
so talking on sort of sex relationships
dating that was a good transition i
would like to pull a quote from my bible
sex in the city i pray by this
i love it they said
why withholding from sex in a
relationship could be
a good thing or not right so according
to sex in the city
who made up this three-date rule they
made it famous
saying sleep with someone earlier and
you appear too eager
leave it too long and you've wasted your
time if they turn out to be a dud
in bed now this could be like it could
go either way because sometimes
you know there's nothing wrong with
having sex at the first date and there's
nothing wrong with waiting
four months to have sex but is there a
perfect sort of happy medium here
i'd say the happiest medium is when you
feel
safe with someone you feel like this is
a safe choice
not like they're you're like love you i
i feel safe i
feel turned on and
i've had like and and and i feel like i
trust this person no matter what happens
i i in my i think this is about women i
feel that i want to and i'm making the
decision
with a clear mind a clear heart and i'm
going to have sex right now like i'm
going to do it but
i think it's the times where we wait too
long because we're playing the game
or we go too quick because we don't want
them not to like us or we get too drunk
i mean believe me like
i've done all the things right you get
drunk you're like ah why did i do that
because you lose your inhibition so i
think
you know generally i think the rule is
when i i don't have i don't believe in
these rules like wait till the fourth
date or no
no sex before commitment i to answer
your question i think it's when you feel
ready and you're not pressured
it's not outside things it's not because
i want
something else from this person it's
like no i actually
feel good with this person and i want to
do it now i think yes
people have sex on the first date and
they get married and stay together
forever all the time you hear those
stories
but i think generally what i love is the
like i like to wait until and not by
rule but i'm saying what i've found in
time and
is that like i want to get to know
someone i want to know like
and i love like when we make out we want
to like tease in the sense of
the anticipation till the next time i
see them and getting to know who they
are as a person what are they what are
they into do i have fun with them
because what can happen is
when we do have sex too quickly
sometimes like on the first date
then we barely know the person but we
get
attached to the sex and then we're like
oh my god it was so hot or we think i
want to correct what happened
and then it gets messier so just to be
like you know
i liked hooking up with them and not
going all the way or whatever it is it's
like i feel like that
generally is something to think about
that you don't want to win anything and
pay attention to your body
absolutely i always think about it's
always the mindset you're going to go
into it i feel like you do have an idea
of how you want to maybe go maybe
sometimes you're like oh i didn't even
think i was going to end up doing it but
i
felt it in the moment and i wanted to do
it so if this is a guy that maybe
you're like really just feeling it right
off the bat and it's just that sexual
energy and everything go for it but know
what
is going to maybe happen later the
dynamic could be different and maybe
fear of him not calling you back yeah
be okay with him not calling you i think
that's exactly like
you know what i'm doing this because i
want to if i didn't really believe it if
i don't hear from
tomorrow fine if i never see him again
my entire body a hundred percent i'm
making this
decision to essentially have sex i will
take the repercussion whatever happens
because i wanted it it's like you went
to a movie
like and you're like i decided to go to
movie tonight if it sucks that's fine
i'll eat the 20 bucks
to go in the theater and i'm gonna go
it's like that kind of thing it's a risk
it's a thing
but you wanted it so that's great advice
that is honestly such good advice and i
think a lot of people
will seriously do that i know i'm gonna
do that too because i
there is like this weird pressure i
think at least for me no one puts it on
me that i put on myself
i do too i think we both have pressures
in different ways like for me i'm always
thinking
i need to make sure this guy is fully
committed ready to go like if i do sleep
with him he won't leave like there's a
lot of labor it's just not setting that
expectation for that person
because i do like having a connection
with someone like i do that's something
well it makes it better
it makes yeah it does it's bad that's
true i think most of us
i think most of us would say and
including men
but i don't know i can't speak for
everyone but like when we have a genuine
connection and we
like the person and we feel safe with
them i think safety is a big thing too
you know most women and this is like
you know studies scientific studies they
have the data that women
are more likely to have more pleasure
and more orgasms when they felt when
they're with
a partner that they feel safe with and
so typically you don't
so that's why the elevator sex or the
first night sex it's going to be good
but is it going to be the best sex of
your life it's going to get better after
that
absolutely very good point okay well
we're going to move on to listener
questions there were heaps of them that
came in when we told people that you're
coming on so we'll just do a few
give your advice cool okay so the first
one is
reasons for why people cheat is it me or
them
and how to move forward and not carry
that into the next relationship
people cheat for so many reasons and
it's like people are gonna cheat again
not about you
it's probably it's about them it's about
their own insecurities
their own stuff they haven't worked
through it could be because they want
attention
or it's because it felt good in the
moment or they were
drinking or they are a fear of a
of a vulnerability or connection like
there's so many reasons why people cheat
but i i just
there's not one like oh it's because
you're because usually we take it on us
and i have found this that women usually
think well it's
something's wrong with me because i did
something wrong or i'm a bad person and
i find more with men if they get cheated
on and women
cheat just as much as men that they're
more like
you know they don't ever like take that
ego stuff and then they're more like oh
yeah you know i guess uh you know he's
she's an [ __ ] or whatever like but
it's it's all these reasons i mean
there's not one but it's it's not
because we did something wrong
it's usually because well i don't know i
was good to say that
couples if you're talking about things
if you have healthy communication not
just in the bedroom not just about sex
but about everything and you're like are
we in a committed relationship
do i want to be committed did i blindly
sign up for monogamy with a guy i've
been dating for six weeks and why is
that what did i do to feel
safe did i do it because i don't want
him sleeping with other people but then
do i actually want to be in this
relationship
i don't so i cheated like there's so
many reasons but if you are
talking to a partner in a real way like
do we want this do we not what does
monogamy look like to you
then the cheating won't happen as much
and maybe it's okay to sleep with a few
people at once like that's what
so all the reasons monogamy is tough
and i have theories about monogamy we're
like i just don't know how
forever is a thing but we'll get we'll
get to that when we get to that
i agree with i agree i don't think that
you should in your 20s i think it's a
great time
if you want kids i get it i get like
okay well we're going to be monogamous
right right now like have fun and
explore and again this is not for
everybody he's like i can't handle that
but then don't but for some people it's
like
i want to have fun and be honest about
it because if talk on a dating app
and you assume that for three days
they're off the app or they're not
sleeping with anyone else and you
haven't had a conversation like
you're wrong totally oh that was good
that's a good answer i love that
so the next one is if the sex was
awkward and bad the first time
do you give it another chance and which
is kind of a weird
word but i i get that because you think
about it if someone's horrible the first
time you do it
are they just going to continue it's
like it does it's a turn off
honestly for some people you're just
like oh god like if is it off is it
between us or is it
what do you think about you might as
well i'd say if you really like the
person give it another shot
have a conversation about it and just
see how it goes a second time because
maybe they were really nervous
maybe you were really nervous or maybe
you're just two pieces in a puzzle that
don't fit together
but you might as well give it another
shot unless it was like
horrible and abusive and you were weird
and they didn't care about you and then
no if it's toxic get out but if it was
just
awkward and fumbly you've never been in
the same naked together
so true see true this one says is it bad
to fantasize about
someone else while in bed with your
partner
everyone it's gonna happen everyone
it's all good let it go let it go it's
all fine let it go okay
the more we accept ourselves and our
fantasies and our desires
the much better off we'll be just let it
go you're fine yeah i love that
that's a good point what are some of the
best foreplay tips to drive
your partner crazy are we talking about
well
you know what i actually want to say
it's the same it doesn't matter the
gender but i think the
the um let's julie do you want to pick a
gender should we talk about men
it says we're all girls let's just do
girls yeah i'll take this girl's advice
so what's how to do it to a guy right
like how to yeah more play tips for a
guy
i would say um i would say slowing
everything down
i'd say go five times slower i would
slow down the kissing
i would tease i would you know kiss uh
i would i would make sure you said well
i'm thinking about like oral sex but set
an atmosphere
and i would say if they're coming to
your house
make sure that everything's clean like i
love thinking about all the senses being
engaged like it also gets me in the mood
so
i light a candle i have music playing
maybe i have some like my favorite food
out like chocolate or
and i make sure that i'm feeling good
and i'm wearing something maybe that i
feel
sexy and not necessarily for them so to
me it's like make sure the environment
set up
and then i would say for touch like just
kiss slowly
and kiss down there but do i would say
do what you
do what you would want so slow it down
and dress them
you know um tease like you know touch
over their pants like make them like
you know want it yeah i think the slow
is
i've never heard that answer that's
actually really genius just slow
everything down and to do
and wear and do what you feel you're
sexiest in because then
you'll lose this different sort of vibe
about you and then they'll be like oh my
god why is she so attractive right now
enjoyed it because it's it's supposed to
be a fun time like you're supposed to
experience this thing together and you
shouldn't rush it
totally and they're dying for someone to
take the lead i mean think about it my
heart goes out to men because they're
like told
i gotta make the date i gotta ask him
out have to make the first move
and so if you're a woman who that and
i'm saying you know what you want
because again we're all on the journey
but in the moment what you might need
to feel in your body to be ready for
someone a lover like that's great
foreplay yeah
totally okay i think this is the best we
chose this one to answer last because
it's really just makes sense
um one great sex tip for people to use
in 2021
it could be it didn't even be about safe
sex it could just be like
let's start a new sex thing 20 20
likes i would say talk i would say
i would just say communication is
lubrication talk about sex and the other
thing is use lube
i would love you to talk about sex and
have a lube on your nightstand because
women the lube is better lube makes
every kind of sex better whether it's
masturbation or
ever oral everything yeah they have more
orgasms
the last part we had someone come on a
couple of months ago named zoe logan and
she literally said the same thing and we
never even like talked about
blue before luke is underrated i guess i
guess it's like
lube that's something yeah
like like get some i love pure lube it's
called pj you are
pure put it on your nightstand have it
in your thing and be like
like i do this now i i will not have any
kind of sex i'm like okay let me get the
lube like it's just
it's just in my brain and they love it
too it's not just like
it's again it's the stigma they think oh
well lou means she's not turned on
because i did something wrong
and your wetness level is not an
indicator of how how turned on you are
how much you're in the mood it just
means like we're not consistent with our
wetness
a year of lube that's emily do you have
one do i have what
a sex tape that sucks up for 20 21.
i have one all right what's yours okay
go ahead
bring back facetime sex because we're in
corona virus
yes spice it up social distance yeah
i love it it's all about that right now
right yeah
slowing it down yeah yeah
i think amazon order like fun costumes i
think
do roleplay oh like fun i mean
i think corona hopefully this whole
thing lifts but like really have fun
with it like just have fun
i feel like people are still can get a
little like nervous about it but
have a drink put it on a costume
expects fun again this year i think
totally so this is what
this is what hopefully we want all the
listeners to do order your costumes grab
your lube and facetime your mans or
girls
exactly that's what you're gonna do
thank you so much for coming
we love you so fun i adore you both
and hit me up if you have ever questions
just like reach i mean personally you
know what i'm saying that guys
i want you guys to win at this oh thank
you so much we absolutely love you
we'll hopefully see you once this
pandemic is lifted i know i want to give
you a hug
well thanks for coming on again bye have
a good night bye
good day